good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday hope
everyone is having a great day i'm
having a great day i'm feeling very
stamp of approval because i am joined by
tiktok pr marketing branding queen gbt
girl boss town your real name is robin
but like i will never call you anything
other than gbt perfect is that okay yeah
of course sometimes when people see me
in the street they're like girl boss i
feel that's like a lularoe ad i'm like
yeah it's good but it's from it's giving
emma mlm
of course okay i have so many questions
for you before we dive in thank you so
much for being here thank you i need
someone to just kiki but there's so much
going on in the pop culture space we're
coming off the oscars and like i think
that you really match my energy in terms
of being like you could talk about this
[ __ ] for hours endlessly i grew up
reading us weekly not hooked on phonics
exactly not highlights magazine no no
so for those who may not be familiar you
have blown up in the last like three
months it's crazy yes you are a tick
talker but you do really interesting
content like [ __ ] nobody else does which
is why i feel like your content is very
unique you're all about pr branding
marketing like you evaluate
certain crises you're always giving
people advice you're giving brands
different ideas on how to elevate their
branding so tell me about your
background like are you a marketing
major like yes well i was a
communications major but i always say
like none of the stuff that i talk about
i learned in college by the way same and
same i was a communication major
i think that the reason why i like am
like this is because i grew up watching
reality tv and just being the ultimate
consumer of pop culture so when you're
the ultimate consumer you know what
people want because like i have the
brain of like the audience that it's
targeted towards and i like did
marketing classes in high school you
know like sold the cookies like yeah
shout out to high school north um but i
was in corporate marketing jobs
for a minute but for like health
insurance companies and like i could
truly care less 100 you know what i mean
and then i was like i am just going to
quit this i'm going to go to esthetician
school so i can get free filler for the
rest of my life love love love that for
you yes and when i quit i started
bartending and i had a lot of time
during the day so i started uploading
tick tocks um and then it just kind of
took off i am not an esthetician school
um
not yet i mean legally you should follow
through just on that for like a hobby
yeah no of course i love it so much but
um yeah i basically i started doing pr
moves on tick tock and it was an effect
where everybody commented do me next to
me next time differently not in my
dating life life it wasn't do me next
but like for the tick tocks um but
then bran started seeing that and now i
do creative consulting for a lot of
brands so it's not like your typical
influencer no brand relationship so i do
a lot of that on the back end but um i'm
also like creating an audience with like
gbt doing the stamp of approval okay so
i feel like if you don't have a tick
tock you might have no idea what we're
talking about but you really blew up
when you were doing different like ideas
you were having for other influencers
being like this influencer should do a
partnership with this brand yeah and
then release this book or this
documentary and then all these
influencers start and brands started
commenting like do me next do me next
yeah and then you literally how many
followers did you get like in that
couple weeks
175 000. that is so crazy yeah and your
life has just been completely changed
right i was doing side work at a
restaurant in like october like watching
silverware and then in january i was at
e news i was like this is crazy it's so
good it's the power of social media and
i also just want to say if there's
anybody watching this who thinks oh it's
too late to get on tick tock i kind of
miss the waves right it's definitely not
no um just don't come from my position
but like it's not too late it changed my
entire life and this is a dream i'm a
massive toaster i've been a toaster from
the start yeah so
everything i'm doing is amazing and
thank you so much for talking about that
but this is my
we just love
love to hear that here at the morning
toast i love you for being here i cannot
wait i know
you can i see i watch all your videos
pretty much and i think you get similar
um
not backlash but feedback about being
like too obsessed with the kardashians
they call me a vapid waste of space i
love that
not that i read the comments or anything
no no of course not and by the way same
yeah um i
i seriously i i could talk about the
kardashians till the day i die yeah and
i i just want to do like a little speed
round of questions for you one like
which kardashian do you relate to the
most who do you love the most so um og
like early seasons chloe currently kim i
i have three sisters as well um so we
used to like fist fight over the
straightener so i like get that vibe
energy but i feel like right now i'm in
my kim era like i'm not becoming a
lawyer but same vibes i totally love
that i mean businessman beau attire
you're looking snatched to the guy thank
you it's giving kim kardashian oh my god
okay another kim kardashian related
question like what is your take on the
whole kanye thing i know people are so
sick of hearing about it but i do want
to get your yeah definitely so um i
don't like to speak too specifically on
it because i definitely think it is like
mental health related and like
there's a difference between pop culture
and like
this is serious agreed um but i have the
same big three as kanye well that's the
big three like horoscope oh my gosh so i
i relate to him a lot and i'm a massive
massive kanye fan i think he's a genius
and i love him but what's been happening
recently he's not a pee job no not
giving p john energy whatsoever
whatsoever what is your sign i'm a
gemini sun cancer rising pisces moon
okay but like what month were you born
may 31st so what does that make you
gemini thank you okay so you're toxic
yes exactly that's all i know about
horoscopes and that i'm a cancer i don't
even know ben's horoscope and
it's going to be extremely hot take like
i don't believe in them um moving on yes
um i hear that you have prepared some pr
moves some some cons creative consulting
yeah suggestions for the morning totes
please i would literally love to hear
that okay so it's kind of like that so
raven like these ideas just like come
into my brain and um i write them down
in my notes and my phone okay first and
foremost i think you should do a collab
with tony morgan on toasters i'm kidding
but like that would be iconic best one
you've had yes but speaking of sonia i
think you guys definitely need to have a
booth at bravocon and in the morning and
like you guys could
actually like serve like different types
of toasts and spritz and then interview
the bravo um bravo liberties obviously
very own brand i think to launch like
you do great on tick tock
no i don't you do i do you do follow
your own ticket agreed um but i think
you should start toast talk where
there's a question about pop culture
like a pop culture story that you
covered that day and um or the previous
day and in 60 seconds or less you dive a
little bit more into it okay so like the
most popular story of the day
um dive into it a little bit more on the
toast every single day in 60 seconds or
less toast talk cute kitchen love love
love love love love i think for spritz
you guys need to have a spritz um
single taken spritz dating event where
each color represents if you're like
single taken or like mingling oh my god
that's like such a good idea yes um and
a little bit on that and with dating i
think that sofia court and the snatcher
and you guys need to have like a
bachelorette type series sponsored by
spritz and it could be at a bar and you
guys could like um remember when in kim
and chloe take miami they like vet guys
for quite a quarter to date with kind of
like that but i feel like sophia the
court like you guys are very good for
love she is like embodies like yeah in
new york spirits yeah
write a theme song for the toast and you
guys do like an american idol moment on
one episode where they all come on and
like audition it
love yes love love love love i'd like to
be a judge too of course oh my god wait
those were really good ideas thank you
how long did that take you to come up
with like five minutes really yeah so
people are always like what's your
process like they they get so deep they
want me to talk about like colleges and
i'm like honestly i like watch watching
old episodes of america's sex top model
and kardashians get my br my brain going
and then i just look at somebody's
instagram and it's like that's a raven
moment just comes to me we were rooting
for you we were all rooting for you how
dare you how dare you tiffany no and you
know what those were such good ideas and
i feel like brands pay you like a lot of
money and like we just got it for free
so this has been worth it you can go
thank you so much thank you guys no i'm
totally kidding she's going to join me
for the past five i can't wait to get
your take on i'm still just like reeling
from the oscars i'm not over it i can't
get over it and i know this sounds like
so dramatic but like i have not been
able to sleep like it's just been on my
mind
it's so crazy and now there's a lot of
rumors going around that this whole
thing was staged i don't believe it was
me neither i didn't even make it a story
because it's not real people were like
it was a stage slap and there's just no
way in hell that it was fake no i mean i
think um
[ __ ] slapping somebody and also i hate
when people come on the show and they're
like can i swear i'm like fake fan yeah
you know you can swear on the show
literally [ __ ] slapping zombie is not a
pr move um
having a relationship with somebody
is a pr move but doing that on live
television especially with the oscars
where everything has to be vetted this
is like a massive night in television
like that is not a pr move okay and i i
hope once we get to the story you're
gonna give some of your suggested pr
moves because will is it's crazy when i
look for stories in the morning for the
show literally every it's multiple
multiple stories on every single website
will smith this will smith that
jimmy kimmel gave his take on will smith
it's crazy i know it's insane and
honestly like i'm a massive will smith
fan
he was turning into jason derulo a
little bit on tick tock remember when
jason gerulio is doing like out of
control out of control tick tocks with
like high
like quality editing yeah a little weird
but at the bottom yeah it's not the vibe
stop
stop but i love will smith but after
this happened it was like my whole life
flashed in front of my eyes for him i'm
so glad you're matching my level of
drama queen because i couldn't agree
more and the thing is like how my brain
works too i'm like what is that phone
call he got like the next morning right
like what does that look like what were
people in the control room doing like
freaking out freaking out even people in
the front row like it was just beyond
you know there's going to be a hulu
documentary on it in like two years i'm
so ready for it right now yeah okay so i
think without further ado we should dive
into the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
the new starbucks bia energy drink with
caffeine naturally found in coffee fruit
it's energy that's good it's a beverage
that's crafted from caffeine naturally
found in coffee fruit as well as
antioxidant vitamin c it includes three
delicious fruity flavors mango guava
raspberry lime pineapple passion fruit
we do have them in the studio i do drink
them before the show in case you can't
tell because you guys know i like really
don't drink coffee but these are super
delicious it's a refreshing flute
flavored boost of energy
in a way that only starbucks can deliver
each 12 ounce 90 calorie can can contain
160 milligrams of caffeine so you'll be
buzzed and ready to talk as fast as we
are start spar
starbucks bia energy drink is available
online at grocery stores convenience
stores and gas stations nationwide
personally i love the raspberry lime but
every girl has their own flavor profile
check it out i think you'll enjoy it
today's episode is also brought to you
by wonderskin
new beauty brand that we're obsessed
with here at the morning toast it's
taking over my tick tock for you page um
they're winning tons of awards and
you've probably seen their videos of the
peel and reveal lip stain it's the
coolest lip product that i've personally
ever used you put it on your lips it's a
it comes out blue as a mask and then you
miss their activator in seconds you peel
off the mask revealing a beautiful lip
color that is transfer proof waterproof
feather proof and it will last for 10
hours this product has won the most
prestigious allure best of beauty
breakthrough reward you have to try it
but don't stop there they also have the
best skincare that we're obsessed with
it's called pierbock which you've spoken
about a lot here at the morning toast um
it's literally the opposite of covering
up their three products that work
together to give you flawless looking
skin with a beautiful glow and you'll
see the results after the first time you
use it and you'll get meaningful results
in just four weeks for the first time in
years we can leave our house confidently
without any cover-up makeup just
pierbock
so we've been using wonderskin products
for a while now and as we said we're
obsessed they create products unlike
anything we've tried before and the best
part is they all work and have made a
difference in both my makeup and my
skincare routine and their liquid gym
sculpting serum is amazing it helps to
better define and sculpt my face reduce
puffiness if you have a big
round face like me right now if you go
to wonderskin.com use the promo code
toast you'll receive 20 off plus free
shipping on orders of 50
or more that's 20 off when you go to
wonderskin.com use the promo code toast
okay gbt are you ready i am so ready
okay the first story obviously the
biggest news is that will smith has
issued an apology he took to instagram
and he apologized to chris rock for
slapping him at the 2022 oscars here's
what he said
violence in all of its forms is
poisonous and destructive
my behavior at last night's academy
awards was unacceptable and inexcusable
jokes at my expense are part of the job
but a joke about jada's medical
condition was too much for me to bear
and i reacted emotionally i would like
to publicly apologize to you chris i was
out of line and i was wrong i am
embarrassed and my actions are not
indicative of the man i want to be there
is no place for violence in a world of
love and kindness i would also like to
apologize to the academy the producers
of the show and the attendees and
everyone watching around the world i
would like to apologize to the williams
family and my king richard family i
deeply regret that my behavior has
stained what has otherwise been a
gorgeous journey for all of us i'm a
work in progress sincerely will and then
he copy and pasted that and made it his
caption as well we love a notes app
apology we do this one's kind of
gorgeous it's black and white it's not
notes app it's it's a little elevated
yeah i will say i think he should have
pulled the jersey shore and been like
chris the last night at bed um when you
put your head in between two waitress's
breasts um but i think this needs a
little bit more of a serious apology not
just like ron and sam i know
i don't know how i feel about it though
because it's almost like the damage is
done
um and like saying you're sorry on a
notes app apology and giving like a
public statement is the first step and
like i believe that everybody can be
forgiven um besides my ex-boyfriends um
but um
it's all gonna be talk about like his
actions like going forward i it makes me
so sad though that like this kind of
like tainted his like legacy a little
bit and you know and the biggest night
of his career and also i feel really bad
for like venus and serena's like family
like how awkward is that beyond and then
venus's nipple popped out yeah i mean
like it was just not it was not the
night yeah it was king richard it was
not the night i i have to say i do
appreciate this apology because honestly
i wasn't sure if he was going to stand
by it
or not and i've seen a lot of discourse
online where people are you know
justifying it and they feel as though it
was like the right thing for him to do
and comedians are the enemy so i wasn't
sure if he was good there are people
like supporting what he did so i'm like
he could lean into that yeah and not
even have to apologize so i have to say
maybe my bar is low but i'm glad he
doesn't stand by what he did and he's
like remorseful of it because he could
have gone the other way and it would
have been okay because a lot of people
are down with tiffany haddish was on the
red carpet saying it was like the
greatest thing she ever saw she wished a
lot of people are standing behind him
right so he could have just leaned into
that and not apologize and moved on
but it's like
was that fully him
the apology yeah where it was something
he thought he had to do because there's
like so much backlash they're talking
about like stripping him of his award
which i think is dramatic um but we'll
never know i know so like for face value
i'll take it for what it is yeah i
appreciate it but i think going forward
like he's definitely gonna be on red
table talk uh a hundred percent and
chris rock is gonna go and call her
daddy
and we're gonna get both sides of the
argument honestly the only person i'm
like dying to hear from is chris rock i
know and i don't know if he'll do
anything and it's did you see the meme
where it was like um will smith from
shark tale and um chris rock from um
madagascar is like the fact that we saw
these two fights
it's
it's the craziest thing do you think
chris rock will speak out no chris rock
is like a celebrity
in name only like he doesn't really
have that like relationship with fans he
doesn't do he's very much like behind
the scenes he does his work he lives in
new jersey he doesn't live in l.a he's
not like that i actually don't think we
will hear from him ever like again on
this
and something that i noticed after i
watched it for like the 12th time yeah
is he says after he's like i'm not going
to speak on it anymore and he goes i
could say so
yeah next so it's like
what's he about to go in on will smith
well there is like a deep history with
will smith and jada with chris rock like
this isn't the first time like chris
rock has gotten in trouble over a joke
he made a joke in 2016 also
so there's obviously like a distaste
there's like not good vibes and what i
think is interesting is like p diddy
the night of the event was like talking
to reporters was like it's all good i
can guarantee you like it's been settled
and then reports were coming out like
the two have not spoken to each other so
this public apology is nice like did he
apologize personally privately i don't
know i don't know either and honestly
the fact that this happened on live
television it's beyonce and the girl who
you know how they didn't bleep it in
australia but there's like a somebody
doing like subtitles or speaking in the
background of it yeah she's having her
moment because like everybody is posting
that yeah and i was like if that was me
i'd be like so excited so it was lupita
nyong'o like yes could she have had a
better seat no and she's like this yeah
no she's like shook i think she's also
like is this a skit yeah no i think
that's what everybody was but i saw
tuffy was there and i texted her and she
was like it was silent after it happened
yeah awkward silence and the way we
really knew that it was so real and
that's why i don't even buy into any of
the people who were like it was fake
because chris rock is a professional
he's the biggest comedian in the world
he doesn't really mince words he doesn't
stumble over himself and he was like
visibly shooketh and he was like
stumbling over the teleprompter yeah his
words he was like fumbling he was
talking about documentaries out there
yeah like he was just not well of course
not i don't think anyone could even in
that moment grasp what was going on let
alone having to go on with the show and
he did as good of a job as he could have
done but that's how there's no way in
hell this was fake the fact that he got
slapped and then had to talk about like
planet earth it's just like there's like
a lot and no and you know what like this
is why the oscars have been so boring
for so many years because they didn't
have hosts and then people weren't
slapping each other right and now it's
like there's all this backlash and we're
gonna talk about the next story which is
some backlash amy schumer's getting it's
like you wanted comedians you wanted the
show to be funny this is what happens
yeah so if you don't like it let's go
back to the boring no no hosts two-hour
show and nothing comes of it well what i
was gonna say is i think that
there's people on chris rock and will
smith's team like equally because it's
like it was about jada's medical
condition which is horrible and that's
why i'm like oh my god like will smith
did the right like not the right thing
but he had ever his wife he had every
right to be upset and when you're upset
about something you go over to the
person especially if you know them
personally which i believe they do and
you tell them you're upset with them but
then with comedians it's like that's
what the people wanted out of the oscars
yeah what i mean david spade said the
perfect thing it was like
there's literally the comedian on stage
has no clue of everyone's medical
history and i am a pop culture girly
there's nothing on this planet i don't
know and i had no idea jada pinkett
smith had alopecia i thought it was a
personal choice because i think she
looks great stunning and i thought it
was like a style thing so i didn't even
know that i think there's very little
chance chris rock did and if there was a
conversation to be had afterwards they
could have worked it out yeah
so i stand firmly on team comedian
i'm seeing online that's kind of an
unpopular opinion um and a lot of people
are
you know praising will smith for
standing up for his wife and don't get
me wrong like if someone says something
about me like ben you better go over
there and take care of it but violence
is never that's not what i'm referring
to i like strong words yeah um so this
just will continue to be the thing i
will think about for the rest of my life
for the rest of my life um and now more
backlash drama and this one i just
really can't with and like i'm about to
go off is about amy schumer
who i have to say
i'm i feel like i've been critical of
amy schumer i'm not like a big amy
schumer fan i love her movies i have to
say i feel pretty is one of my favorite
movies and trainwreck is amazing too but
i'm just not
i'm not a huge amy schumer girly so just
know that i'm not even being biased
right now she is now getting backlash i
can't she has to address the backlash
over the kirsten dunst seat filler joke
so amy schumer defended her joke where
she called kirsten dunst a seat filler
at the oscars after some viewers dragged
her as being disrespectful to the
actress she said hey i appreciate the
love for kirsten dunst i love her too
that was a choreographed bit she was in
on i wouldn't disrespect that queen like
that um and as you guys know she did
this bit where she sat next to i can't
remember his name from friday night like
landry
[Laughter]
literally
um where she sat next to kirsten dunst's
husband and was like oh see filler can
you get up i need to talk to your
husband whatever um it was obviously a
joke one it was hilarious too i wish amy
didn't even respond to this because like
when you respond to backlash especially
moronic backlash like this you're giving
light to it and like as a comedian like
you should just be able to do a bit i
was pretty sure kirsten dunst was in on
the joke even if she wasn't it was still
a funny joke kirsten dunst is the
biggest actress she's nominated for an
oscar like we all know who she is it was
a joke like i got the door tour
thank you yes
thank you yes yes
i hate this i hate everyone and justice
for amy schumer but also can we just
talk about how her husband is a
critically acclaimed actor as well and
like i only know him as landry clark who
had acne and killed somebody and then
his dad like burned the car no of course
i also know him from breaking bad that's
where i like got my second dose of
landry but he will always be
dylan
literally he will always use tyra
colette
so
friday night lights to me and i can't i
agree i cannot see him as anything other
than like i know his last name no what
is it clark landry clark yeah yeah yeah
that show is like
honestly a work of art it so it's my
favorite the first season of that show
i can't watch it without getting full
body chills and i'm like i am so [ __ ]
lame no you're not when i hear the theme
song like i actually cry yeah and when
like matt is singing mr sandman to his
grandma after the first date like come
on
and tim riggins if you're watching this
which you're not
like don't by the way do not be
well kim watches and kylie literally
everyone watches the toast like i would
not be surprised if this got to tim
morgan's death so if there's something
you want to say to tim regan feel free
to speak directly into the camera um
texas forever
inside of me please
i agree and by the way taylor kitch is
like still so hot but he will never be
as hot as he was in friday nights it was
the hair it was the dirty house it was
the dirty clothes it was the alcoholism
it was everything it was the hooking up
with his best friend's girlfriend
that show he's like i actually need to
re-watch it but like it i rewatched it
recently and it's so good i think why
people are so connected to it is like it
really romanticizes high school and like
the best time in your life and when
you're in high school you don't realize
like these are the days that you'll
remember for the rest of your life
you're just like oh i have to go to math
class yeah but it really it captures
that time when you're like 17 18 you're
like falling in love and it just
romanticizes it and i think that's why
we all watch it and we go back and watch
it it's like yes that was us like
everyone high school was horrible
anyways it was before social media so
it's romanticizing you falling in love
for the first time without like the guy
liking other girls bikini pictures yes
so simple too because it's in the small
town in texas and it's just like it's so
and the coach
coach taylor ain't it good to be the
coach have you ever seen the amy schumer
skate where she pretends to be um
coach taylor's wife but i love how you
just circled it back to amy schumer
thank you that's what i do here at the
morning toast yeah circle back talents i
want your take on the kirsten dunst
so
um
as i stated previously like i got the
door tour
is
truly it would be like i should make it
my instagram biome you should bring it
on is
the best piece of art
ever i couldn't agree more like sparky
palastry come on
those are not spirit things i like i'm
dropping last names too yes you're a
first-year-lasting birthday lassie for
sure um i don't think this is a big deal
at all like
i don't think kirsten dunst cared
like
she
is a queen she was nominated for an
oscar with her husband who was also
nominated for an oscar i mean if she got
second place to these um the east
compton clovers right she can handle she
can handle an oscars joke and honestly
like as i said um
gossip girl like all press is good press
in a sense like if you're being talked
about at the oscars even if it's a joke
i would be like oh my god i am the seat
filler [ __ ] yeah like come out with
merch seat filler merch there are so
many famous people in the room so to be
acknowledged
there could be a hundred people in a
room and amy schumer's talking about you
like it's a and you know what like all
this backlash to like these jokes is
bothering me so much like i honestly
hope the oscars never has a comedy host
again like leave comedians alone like
you want us to make you laugh and then
you're going to go cry about it like
[ __ ] off i'm i just think like everyone
is being a loser right now this is
quaking no and you know what as much as
i would literally give up my left breast
to have joan rivers be alive right now
i'm grateful she's not alive to see this
it would work yeah it would it would
never but there's so many moments where
i'm like if only we had joan like the
voice of reason yes because once she
speaks like it's over like whatever
jones says it's gospel it's like the gbt
of
yeah but approval
carpet oh my god i love that would you
ever do like what is your goal from all
of this like do you want to do red
carpet hosting what do you want to do so
i might be doing some red carpet hosting
next week yeah fingers crossed for
something like my bucket list yeah um
but i mean i did e-news like those were
like my
younger like dreams and goals everybody
wanted to be on english
exactly when i was in communications
class my first day and like my first
semester for
being a communications major it was like
communications 101 we ought to go around
like say what we wanted to be every
[ __ ] was like i want to be the next
julianna ransack i'm like good luck yeah
no literally same like brielle biermann
yes
exactly yeah that was such a good
episode of don't be tardy thank you for
referencing it was incredible yeah um
but so i did that it was so dope but i
think out of all of this i love pop
culture so much like it's literally my
religion but what i like to do
career-wise is definitely like the
consulting i would love to open up my
own creative agency or yeah like a
creative director for a brand and then
keep working with brands i basically
want to be like if garyvee and chris
jenner had a baby who had a tick tock i
love that i was gonna give you like a pr
move and i was going to say like your
long-term goal should be like opening up
an agency yeah like because i could see
like myself going through a scandal and
then like putting you on retainer yes
because you're like in you're you're in
touch with what's going on
you're
innovative and i think that would be
like a great and i also think that like
since i am such a consumer of pop
culture and like we're not even going to
get into like the cancer culture of it
all because i agree exactly with what
you said in your book and i do think
it's dying down a little bit i do too
but i think having like a voice of
reason like when i talk about these
things on my tick tock and i'm just like
this normal girl who's like from new
hampshire on her couch talking about it
and giving my opinion being like well
look we have to look at it on both sides
of things it kind of like makes it more
like realistic
and it like humanizes it it humanizes it
because i mean we have seen so many like
notes app apologies i i think apple
needs to do a billboard with like notes
app apologies to talk about the notes
app i love yeah um but
i do i want to open up an agency that's
like my biggest goal and what would the
name be stamp of approval
gbt the agency gbt colon the agency yes
i love that for you
um okay well moving on um
amy schumer did an amazing job i have to
say i thought the three hosts
she was like finally we got a good um
movie about women in hollywood venus and
serena's
dad no there were so many good like that
little monologue she did first of all i
wish there was more of it there were so
i know it's an award show there were so
many awards and like to be honest like
we don't really care like the point of
the show no i know but it's like like we
don't care like megan the stallion
singing bruno
innovative yeah
completely unique never been done before
throw it up put it into it put in a
blender um yeah i i thought the three
hosts where was wanda like there was
just not enough of those three ladies
and each bit they did i thought was
hilarious when sometimes i think a lot
of like the hosting bits that people do
i like roll my eyes out it's like so
cringy yeah no 100 and amy schumer also
got to be with john cena in train wreck
and like i love john cena but i'm
shipping him and nikki forever forever
forever i'm so happy with her in her new
life i do feel like the one that got
away a hundred percent also speaking of
amy schumer things she did in her movies
she also made bill hader hot which is
like an incredible feat yeah it's a
challenge and now he's dating rachel
bielson and i firmly believe like he
would not have no anna kendrick i
apologize um i don't think he would have
been able to get anna kendrick if it
weren't for his work in train wreck and
that's just my hot take of the day yes i
mean if you're dating the inventor of
the cup song your life might have a
couple of challenges but i'm here for it
right if you're also dating the most
annoying girl on the planet like that
well you don't like anna kendrick she's
annoying she's my number one celebrity
that i don't like and i never speak on
celebrities that i don't want oh i
thought you were going to say my number
one celebrity oh my god no
gbt get out of here no no no yeah i
agree there's something about her yeah
but see you know what
i'm so glad you brought this up because
you know i've been thinking out about a
lot lately i'm glad you brought this up
because i just want to like talk [ __ ]
yeah
you know what i've been thinking about a
lot lately anne hathaway
so she actually looked really good in
her most recent red carpet and ever les
mis was the worst thing that ever
happened to her so there was like that
year or two where uh not anna kendrick
and hathaway was having a moment yes in
hollywood but the princess of genovia
literally but us we were like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] we hate her for no good reason
she was a little annoying not a crime
and she did say she was gonna use her
oscar as a weapon against self-doubt
which is an annoying thing to say and
and she deserved the backlash
but like she didn't really do anything
and we all just hated her and and i
think it really damaged her like on a
personal and mental health level and now
she's working again but she doesn't
really do press she's not very like
in with the fans she just does her art
and she goes home at night and i think
that's because she's like damaged from
people hating her for no [ __ ] reason
yeah and honestly anna kendrick is
giving that same energy anna kendrick is
annoying but what has she done
the cup song
the cup song is the fact that the cup
song played on the radio like that is
foul it's so true it's so true but again
not a crime not a crime so it's like we
all hate anna kendrick collectively and
i feel as though like in a few years
like we will feel bad the way that i
feel bad now for how i hated anne
hathaway when she'd do anything other
than just like be annoying and have a
bad haircut yeah but honestly
i was in the anne hathaway hating grew
grew
but like princess of genovia like amelia
thermopolis grimaldi like that is like
one of my favorite movies
yeah hair i'd rather talk about voltaire
yeah you know i agree and like the mandy
moore of it all so how you go from that
to being the most hated woman in america
like it is a great accomplishment
honestly i know but she anne hathaway
did look good recently on the red carpet
and that blue dress yes i was like you
know what and that's how like i
flip-flop like literally it's so bad
with pop culture and everybody does the
same same thing like i flip flop so bad
like i saw one good photo of her in a
blue dress and i was like you know what
she's kind of the moment the way that i
now would take a bullet for selena gomez
when i used to talk so much [ __ ]
and i feel embarrassed i feel ashamed i
was wrong
and i love it and i think it was part
rare beauty yeah and part only murders
in the building that really did it for
me and i should have always loved her
like taylor loves her and i trust taylor
swift with my life so it's like taylor
has judgment that
she has decided that celine gomez is
everything of the story like i should
have believed taylor and i didn't and
that's not about cats but not that's the
one thing i can yeah i mean same i can't
cuts
i'm very allergic to all yeah well i
have i have a puppy oh his name is howie
when i asked you if you had pets you
forgot about your dog you said cats no i
said pets okay that was something i
could stop you're making me cry why
howie that's a unique human name
so when i was 12 the name howard just
came into my brain and i was like if i
ever have a dog i'm gonna name the
howard very much kylie how she names her
dog norman yeah um not that i was
hopping on that trend like my white
toenails sure um but yeah howie he's the
cutest shih tzu in the world um
if you're watching this a lot of people
do that
okay hi howie hi howie um so yes this
whole cycle of like hating and loving
celebrities is very toxic yes and one
more thing i saw a meme this morning
that was like
um sometimes i feel bad about saying
that julia fox is annoying because i
have a premonition that i'm lowkey
annoying as well so we say all these
people are annoying but i'm like i'm
[ __ ] annoying you know and i know
like i'm not everyone's cup of tea like
i'm very high energy i know people find
me annoying they find the way i talk
annoying i talk too fast i say like a
lot and so like maybe that's just how i
feel about anna kendrick you know it's
projecting i'm 100 percent projecting my
physical security and honestly like i'm
jealous like iana kendrick i'm like i'm
so sorry i'm sorry like i'm jealous that
you were in pitch perfect because like
that's a dream roll for me yeah you
would kill it i know you're really good
okay i'm so glad i got that off my chest
i actually feel like lighter than ever
and perfect to dive into our third story
which is brought to you by below deck
good day yachties your favorite reality
franchise is charting course for
australia and peacock's new original
series below deck down under on a super
yacht near the great barrier reef it's
not just the waves that rock the boat
each charter of outrageous guests
presents new challenges for the audi
hotties but you can count on them to
work hard and play harder besides there
may be sharks in the water but this crew
has a bite of its own the fan favorite
aisha from below deck med is back she's
chief stew while the hunky newcomer
jason has everyone saying aye aye
captain you're adding in yacht size egos
and dueling deckhands and you can bet
there's drama on the horizon if you're
looking for the ultimate escape pull up
that anchor and come aboard below deck
downunda is streaming now with new
episodes every thursday only on peacock
are you a bravo girly the biggest yeah
what's what are you watching right now
so i have an unpopular opinion and i
know that you're going to disagree with
it but like i love teresa
yeah i know but you're jersey's is my
jersey's my favorite housewives but i'm
recently re-watching rahoney i'm on um
with the episode the b is back where
bethany comes back you say rahony too
yeah i get so much [ __ ] for not calling
it rony
oh no it's for honey no and andy says
roney like it's romy but i say rahoney
yeah no rahoney oh my god i'm
so like relaxed now yes i i watch it all
i i another unpopular opinion opinion
like i loved don't be tardy like i love
kim's okay
not an unpopular for the public but you
know what i mean it is i watch her
instagram live it's like that's that's
where i'm ready i'm gonna one-up you i
watched a one-hour ariana biermann tick
tock live like two days ago oh yeah same
it's like i have a cashmere robe you oh
that's the next level i have cab
cosmetics yeah it's pretty good yeah
they have like really good lip liners of
course yes i mean
on brand on brand um oh one more thing
about below deck they should sponsor a
segment on the show where you talk about
like shift where you talk about like
what ships have sailed for the week and
what ships are coming in about new
relationships in hollywood that is an
unbelievable idea thank you would you
ever do below deck
i have been reached out to a trip really
yeah and i was like oh being on a
bathing suit camera no thanks yeah i
mean love island like i could never but
it's my favorite and you have to pay for
it but it's like way discounted like
whatever the cost of like a four-day
charter on a private yacht would be yeah
it's probably like half but i feel like
i'm not paying 60 grand for you to put
my fat ass on tv like no well no first
of all second of all i feel like you
learned your lesson on say yes to the
dress oh honorable yeah i would be like
a difficult charter guest yeah no same
just because i want to get like blacked
out till 6am and then wake up at 10 you
know and go down the slide but at first
when you asked me this is like how in my
brain i was like
i thought you meant to like work on blow
deck like would you
ever be a chiefs too no but like chef
ben
he's a kitty sometimes uh yeah i
i could never go on tv in a bikini only
if it was love island uk
um because it's like my favorite show of
all time yeah and i would have to be
paid approximately 20 million dollars
and then i would do it yeah with the
water bottle yeah of course these are
actually have a love island water bottle
i should have gone i should have worn it
today but it's a little dirty and i
never cleaned the cups but your cup is
clean it's right
as i'm like
no it is clean it's good um okay let's
go into the next story which as an nyu
graduate is beyond painful for me taylor
swift is accepting an honorary doctorate
at nyu and she's speaking at the
commencement at yankee stadium so she's
adding more accolades to her already
impressive lineup the blank space singer
is set to receive an honorary degree
from nyu the school announced on monday
a press release states that swift 32
will receive a doctor of fine arts an
honorary one and will speak at the
graduates to the graduates at
commencement on may 18th at yankee
stadium the degree will be taylor
swift's first as she was already touring
and writing hits by the time she
graduated high school so she doesn't
have a college degree and she
uh nyu also just introduced into their
curriculum at taylor swift class like
in their um clive davis music program so
she's obviously like an nyu girly she's
a good relationship with the school
doing cornelia street
literally and i just want to say like
this kills me because like we had billy
crystal who has done it a thousand times
and i didn't even go so nyu
there's different schools within the
school so every smaller school has like
a radio city music hall or a beacon
theater graduation which is like 10
maybe a thousand or 1500 kids and then
you walk across the stage you get your
diploma but then the big overall school
does it at yankee stadium that's where
the commencement like the big celebrity
speaker is i didn't even go sounds like
i would sweat a lot it was horrible all
my friends were going and i was like
what and i was also like already like
working at the time and i was like i
don't have time for graduation like i
have a job um and the outfit is so not
flattering it's awful it's and you have
to wear it in the heat outside at inky
stadium in may or june i'm like
absolutely not just to hear billy
crystal like no offense billy crystal
it's just like not my personal vibe so
i'm happy for these kids and they're
also doing it for the kids who graduated
last year that's really nice because
they were robbed of so much so i'm happy
for them but like i'm just seating with
jealousy but it kind of sounds like a
brand deal like what is like an honorary
degree you know what i mean like she
deserves an actual degree she agrees she
deserves a doctorate um adam sandler is
from like the area where i'm from so he
always like comes and speaks at like
high school graduations
she's very elevated new hampshire um and
i mean
taylor swift doing this like that's like
a concert like i would want her to
perform she's gonna sing is she gonna
sing what song is she going to walk out
to welcome to new york
see you already it's been i could like
you might be the pr girl but like i am
the taylor swift discography girly like
i could
s
what's the word score an entire day
of someone's life if you don't listen to
i heart question mark get the [ __ ] out
the club 100 um i mean i think it's i
think it's cool i think it's great but
like i just don't really understand
is it are they just like honoring her
but they're giving her a degree yeah
they do this with a lot of celebrities
and i think it's also a way of getting
celebrities to agree to do the
commencement oh you say it's a brand
deal yeah i don't know do you get paid
to do commencement i feel like no even
though these schools are
insanely rich yeah i don't think you do
so i think a way of like enticing big
people to do it is to give them an
honorary degree which like even if
you're really famous like it's pretty
sickening to get yeah i'm gonna get an
honorary degree from like like my nashua
community college to speak i'm gonna get
an honorary degree from like an online
college like phoenix phoenix yeah i have
to say phoenix's branding is gorgeous
like i'm constantly crying at the
university of phoenix commercials yeah
and snhu
that's literally where i'm from oh but
if there's an online school no there's
an actual campus oh but it's crazy
college i went to the university of new
hampshire and then that's when you did
you graduate or you yeah i graduated and
then i moved out to la for two years i
did a program at ucla
um and then i did another program at the
clubs every single night um and yeah
what's the clubs i never heard of that
school yeah no the clubs it it's the
school of hard docs are you at a party
early
i used to be um
but
now it gives me really bad anxiety but
like literally it was out until like 12
o'clock last night so yeah
you're only in new york once yes i like
i love the art and the action of taking
shots like i love i love getting
everybody together into it it's the
chaos and then like i tell everybody
drink drink drink drink drink and then
like everybody's nights get ruined you
have a person you're a neighbor you're
the pusher yeah you push people i will
brock's my favorite movie i would expect
nothing less from someone who stands
taylor swift i'm sorry to correct you
that is a quote from mean girls not
school of rock oh no i'm a pusher i push
people yeah like a drug pusher yeah and
school of rock is
my favorite movie i agreed like i think
there's a list of probably 10 or 15
movies bring it on is on their school of
rock is on there mean girls is on there
clueless is on there legally blonde um
that like shaped who i am as a woman
that's like what i'm always talking
about in my in my book it's like these
films like i was obsessed with tv like
you growing up they shaped who i am like
the monster that i am now like you can
blame it on bring it on yeah no like
sometimes i'll walk around and i'll be
like humming like heal me
oh my god that is an iconic niche
reference yeah with um a minor yeah
no
and that's what i said like literally
being this like
ultimate consumer pop culture and i
think true barrymore and even josh pack
said in his book by the way amazing book
right
how he said like tv was his best friend
like filled up this space when like he
was alone and it kind of raised him i
feel the same way and honestly you know
how there was those ads on tv that
disney channel would go like quiet for
an hour so you could go play outside oh
my gosh because they thought it was time
of the day yeah they thought it would be
like good for the kids i'm like honestly
this is proof that like watching tv can
get you somewhere in life everybody
introduce your kids to tv agreed i was
like one of the only kids like who i was
friends with in high school who had a tv
in their room and it was like crazy like
a tv in your room and you know what i
agree like it was kind of crazy but it
was the best thing that ever happened to
me the best thing ever happened to me i
i love tv there's people who had grew up
with tvs in the room and there's people
who grew up without tvs in their room i
agree and we're a different breed like
we are unique girlies 100 did you watch
a new season of bridgerton yet i haven't
it was okay i've heard mixed reviews
yeah
it was not to be like a freak but there
was like no sex and like that's why
we're tuning in no 100
and i remember when olivia rodriguez
sour was getting big somebody tweeted to
her like i would love to see this in
bridgerton and she did like the eyes
emoji which is like basically uh
text lingo of i have a secret project
coming out yeah right um but people said
that it wasn't in there yeah i do i have
to say the music the way they do those
classical renditions of modern songs is
brilliant and it's beautiful and i watch
the show with captions because i'm like
a grandma now and like i need to just
and they're always talking like
old-timey english i just like need
captions certain shows like i just can't
understand and i love that they tell you
what song it is so they did amazing
songs they did wrecking ball they did
good songs but i don't believe there
wasn't a olivia rodrigo song yeah so i
was looking forward to that and that's
not happening but i mean i'm gonna watch
it i'm always the one that's like i've
heard mixed reviews it's like i'm gonna
watch [ __ ] everything of course i
watched brielle biermann's live stream
on tick tock like i'm going to watch the
new netflix series you know what i would
love to get your pr take on like a hot
button issue that was here at the
morning toast where jackie and i like
maybe a year ago we were just really
trying to decide if olivia rodriguez was
one of the one i wonder i was screaming
and i was like
i was team claudia a hundred percent and
she is the opposite of a one-hit wonder
thank you and like
she's like actually like breaking
records and goals and like and it's been
a year and she's even bigger i think
jackie would now agree that she's not a
one-hit wonder but it's nice to be right
when you're always wrong no
yeah i agree okay let's move on to the
fourth story britney spears is tweeting
and deleting really not tweeting or
posting but yeah she slams her ex
boyfriend justin timberlake and her mom
lin for failing her during her hardest
times in a now deleted instagram post
she said she received a call from jesus
and in a sense deleted instagram caption
she said dear child your mom had a
serving with her book at the exact time
when you needed her most all for what
fame and attention now britney is
referring to her mom's memoir which was
called through the storm a real story of
fame and family in a tabloid world which
was published a year after britney's big
public breakdown following her split
with kevin federline then she unleashed
her unleashed her fury on an unnamed x
as she alluded to justin timberlake's
actions back in 2002
when he released his first album
justified and his diss track crimea
river she wrote your ex did the same
thing he served with his first album
using your name claiming you did him
dirty she wrote obviously everyone knows
justin brady dated for a few years um
she did delete this post but she said
you received a call from jesus who told
her all of these things well you want to
know what's so funny i literally have
been ignoring jesus's calls all day
like i just don't pick up when jesus
goes um i'm a jew so i don't have to
deal with that yeah it sounds like a
carrie underwood song um jesus calls but
um
this is so this is so hard as well it's
like a kanye for me because it's like i
love brittany like i love what she's
been doing she needs makeup remover but
like
i just like
i just
i don't know what to say i know it's you
know what i mean it's like it's like a
car crash like you want to like watch i
mean i hate that saying when people are
like it's like a car crash you want to
watch them like i don't want to [ __ ]
watch it no maybe they're not much bravo
no and i'm like this [ __ ] traffic
like get the [ __ ] out of my way no truly
but like what is there to say about this
and honestly the free britney movement
i have like mixed feelings like i i'm so
happy that she's free from her
conservatorship like rooting for that
the freak britney movement is like such
a crazy moment in pop culture like it's
just like insane what we were able to do
i 100 agree it's a huge like statement
on like the power of social media the
power of fan bases and amanda bynes just
got out of her conservative ship like
justice for amanda bynes i could talk
about amanda bynes yeah she's the man is
on that list of movies yeah and oh of
course my favorite scooter my favorite
scooter as well um
but and i want her to do something with
josh peck like i would love it if they
were in like uh like a rom commerce i
know josh said that like they have not
kept in touch really yeah but he like
loves her and supports her from afar of
course i mean the amanda show uh-huh i
mean
we were i could literally write a
dissertation on how we were robbed of an
amanda buying like career i think she
would have been the biggest female
comedian comic actress yeah of our time
no 100
but back to brittany it's like after
free brittany we're so happy for her and
then she started posting like like new
pictures on instagram she's being a
little while yeah so it's like we were
all like so here for her to get free now
we're like well now that she's free look
at what she's doing it's like we can't
have both you know we wanted we wanted
her to be free and to do these types of
things so i'm just gonna like
look the other way and like support her
you know what i would love to get your
take on because i feel like these last
couple of years with all these
documentaries about brittany about janet
jackson the lifetime movies like it has
not been a good pr couple a couple years
for justin timberlake i feel like he was
really kind of exposed for like the
toxic person he was when he was fully
cheating and they got that picture
yes thank you for bringing that up so as
a pr expert like where does justin
timberlake go from here because there
was a while where he was like really at
the top of his game his music was
incredible he was doing arenas he was
doing stadiums and now he's like kind of
irrelevant he's recording an album with
pharrell um
or like i he posted something like that
like i think he's gonna try to get into
music again i think the fact that his
super bowl halftime show wasn't talked
about but the little kid that took a
selfie with him was that kid is so
annoying he's from massachusetts
sorry and also it's not nice to call it
kid annoying i'm sorry but like he's
well he's like 17 i feel like yeah it's
not gonna keep up with him yeah clearly
but um i think he's gonna try to put out
music but this is the thing
i think what justin timberlake did back
in the day was
foul but then we would have to turn it
on everybody i mean those talk show
hosts what they used to say like it was
so bad so it's like if we're gonna point
the finger at one person like we're
gonna have to flip it on literally the
entire media it was a different time
which is not an excuse whatsoever it's
literally watching those interviews back
like it makes me so uncomfortable it
makes me want to cry no it makes me
literally [ __ ] hate david letterman
so much it's always those clips of david
letterman the way he used to talk to
lindsay lohan like oh i heard you're uh
doing drugs like yeah even pam and tommy
did you watch a show of course it was an
amazing insight into like how jay leno
like [ __ ] jay leno yeah like all those
guys and i'm team pamela like obviously
yeah and i mean if you have big boobs
and skinny arms it's literally like a
hierarchy like that was the first video
that made me go viral and like she is
queen skinny arms
such a good call i could never it's
emerald i have big boobs and bad arms so
like i'm halfway there i'm a fat i'm
girly
[Laughter]
um but
i feel like justin is gonna try to put
out music besides the trolls album um
and even though that song is a certified
bob oh it can't stop the building if you
ask any seven-year-old their favorite
song it's that which is an amazing song
yeah like they don't know mary had a
little lamb anymore they know justin
timberlake and it's stormy webster's
favorite song do you think he should
address like how he's now like
universally regarded as the biggest
piece of [ __ ] on the planet
no
okay i don't think he should address it
because i think it's something we
already know it's like if like something
was on fire and somebody came on i was
like this is on fire it's a fact of life
it's a fact of life so i think that but
it's so unfair like just because he's
like a man like i feel like he's looked
at so differently and can still find so
much success
um that's how i felt about the whole
will smith thing like i kept thinking
imagine if a girl got up there and like
her big ass dress and slapped another
girl or another man who no actually if
it was a man i would be okay with it
slapped another girl who was like
talking [ __ ] already like imagine if
anna kendrick did that no imagine if
nicole kidman got up and slapped amy
schumer
like nicole kidman would be crazy they'd
literally she would have been escorted
out she would be in a conservatorship
lit
literally like that's that's what i keep
thinking about that's like bothering me
so much like no one would be defending
her yeah like britney spears couldn't
even like go to the bathroom by herself
right because
she because she went through a hard time
100 years of trauma right yeah no it's
not fair so justin timberlake is like
and i feel really good about the fact
that like i've hated justin timberlake
like long before it was popular and
that's just me like being a taste maker
yeah hating somebody before everybody
hates them is the best it's the best you
feel and also loving someone before like
i and i i know everyone's tired of
hearing me say this but like i was
yes i was a fan of casey masquerade said
you have two hours to huntington to see
her like i was a fan of casey
masquerades from her first album and
then like obviously she wanted grammy
and everyone was like casey monsters is
amazing like she's playing coachella
like yeah [ __ ] i already knew like an
hour is not your personality no like
really do you know pageant material
because you obviously don't like you
don't wear sorry cowgirl the best song
on the planet yes and the one that
started my friendship with casey
masquerade because i like to put it on
my instagram story and then she
responded to it i didn't tag her in it i
thought she said like this makes me cry
too she was like oh that's so funny that
you said that because dime store cowgirl
also makes my dad cry um and it's like
not even a sad song i'm like i know
casey and then she made me made her show
like it was oh that's so dope yeah like
and now i hear that song and i cry
because like i have open dms with casey
musk graves you know i have open dms
with lil wayne a little different but
like oh tell me about your dms um
do a lot of people slide in asking for
like advice yes a lot there's this is
not to brag whatsoever but please do
there's a lot of blue check marks um and
some are from people that it's like a
little sometimes i'm like it's too late
like really i can't help will you tell
me afterwards of course i'll show you
[ __ ] yes yeah um
but
a lot of it happens through the day yet
through the dm's and you respond to
people and like you give your insights
yeah well yeah or i'll give like my
email like yeah he's like girl you gotta
get paid yeah exactly i love that for
you um okay we only have one more story
which is like making me so sad because i
could talk to you for two hours and it
is brought to you by babel because for
most of us learning a second language in
high school or college wasn't exactly a
high point in our academic careers some
of us were just spent i spent high
school watching friday night lights
but now thanks to babel the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions there's an
addictively fun and easy way to learn a
new language whether you're traveling
abroad connecting in a deeper way with
family or you just have some free time
babble teaches bite-sized language
lessons that you'll actually use in the
real world if you plan on traveling this
summer i went to rome and i did a couple
babbles on the plane and i have to tell
you how much time and energy and like
grief it saved me because just learning
how to say like please thank you
right left is just beyond helpful and it
was super easy with babel you could
choose from 14 different languages
including spanish french italian and
german plus babel speech recognition
technology helps you improve your
pronunciation and your accent there are
so many ways to learn with babble in
addition to lessons you can access
podcasts games videos stories and even
live classes it comes with a 20 day
money back guarantee so you can start
your new language learning language
learning journey today with babble and
right now you can save up to sixty
percent off your subscription when you
go to babble.com tmt that's tmt as in
the morning toast babel is spelled
b-a-b-b-e-l dot com slash t-m-t that's
for up to sixty percent of your
subscription babble language for life
okay the final story is about a man that
like i love and he's toxic um reformed
playboy john mayer says he now sleeps
next to a row of pillows so the 44 year
old reformed playboy lamented during a
recent stob on a stop on his saab rock
tour that people need to stop telling
him to settle down and start a family
he said when are you going to find
someone you don't have kids do you what
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] have i done in my
life to communicate that i don't want to
have kids what are you talking about he
said to the crowd in vegas
um now he said i'm doing fine because
the left side of my bed is just a row of
pillows i sleep next to a row of pillows
sometimes i put my laptop on top of the
row of my pillows sometimes i sneak my
phone in there sometimes i lose my
remote in there but what i mean is the
stack of pillows doesn't resent or hate
me or bring me down oh that's sad for
you john mayer i just want to say this
is like something we were talking about
last week why can we why
singers like should not talk at their
concerts like we don't care first of all
keep singing only taylor only taylor of
course and also like this does not make
john mayer look good like oh your
pillows aren't mean to you you're mean
to literally every girl you date like
have you read jessica simpson's book
yeah i was supposed to say justice for
jessica simpson constantly always and
forever she's my number one she means
the world to me like truly we have the
same birthday like i've been connected
like i i feel very like connected to her
having a celebrity with the same
birthday as you in middle school is
equivalent to bringing a lunchable on a
field trip who's yours um
like oh
what was that show on e he's like
clint eastwood i was going to say he's a
world famous director i was like what's
the show on e my son's family was on it
that show was unique yeah when she heard
that boy band living with them when she
burned the birkin because her her
boyfriend was what's his name
terry
tyler
tyler henry no no that mean
he came on the toe he came on the breath
yes before the breath got canceled he
had a netflix show and the interview
never got aired really yeah but he
didn't read me so i didn't was he like i
feel like no i was wanting him too and
he's like that's not how it works i'm
like okay so what are you doing here
yeah and he was really sweaty with that
tyler guy but yeah um clint eastwood is
mine
a couple things about john mayer um
we've all read jessica's book you know
the truth we literally [ __ ] hate you
but we love you but we literally would
like do anything to have sex with you
giving kim kardashian in kim in courtney
give new york when she's like i'm
dropping hints that i'm single i'm right
i'm single it's like by you saying you
don't want a girl lying next to you in
bed and that you have a bunch of pillows
in your bed makes girls want to go into
your dms and be like i look like a
pillow like squeeze me oh that's
actually a good call your penis was like
a cry this is him dropping hints that
he's not speaking to anybody and wants
somebody to come into his dms
interesting and it might be me but it
will almost i look like a pillow like i
could be the pillow do you share my
sentiment that like while we're really
happy for the life katy perry currently
has like her and john mayer are otp
endgame and yeah no 100 and something
that is like so niche that if you know
this i love the katy perry well one the
katy perry catfish episode where the guy
thinks he's dating katy perry have you
seen it i have not seen it it is my
number one favorite piece sounds really
sad it's like some dog millionaire in my
eyes like my number one piece of media
also in the katy perry documentary which
was
everything part of me when she breaks up
with russell brandt
and justice for katy perry the truckers
are out here for katy perry um and she's
crying before the show and they're like
well it's the rio show they're like we
need you to get on stage this is the
biggest crowd and she goes like this
start the makeup and she gets her makeup
done and then she goes on stage and
starts singing um
the one that got away
iconic
i i couldn't agree more that like if i'm
starting another list of the list of
movies i previously mentioned there's
another list of like celebrity
documentaries that are actually good and
life-changing now everyone has a
documentary and i think the perfect
example of that is shawn mendes netflix
one called wonder which was sorry
atrocious um but there are certain
celebrity documentaries that i feel as
though are works of art
katy perry piece of me are part of me i
can't remember what it's called
lady gaga five foot two getting ready
for the super bowl
joan rivers piece of work is
the best documentary you will ever see
in your life i can't remember which
other ones but like there are certain oh
beyonce's hbo documentary is on there
too there are certain celebrity
documentaries that really capture who
the person is yeah and i agree that that
moment in katy perry's was astonishing
it's all i think about like that's truly
all i think about and i feel like the
reason why celebrities documentaries and
memoirs are so good is because it's
giving us what we get from social media
influencers yes we get a real side of
them we get to see their lives that like
we all think about or maybe not we all
maybe just
um and everyone who listens to this
podcast no yeah but john mayer like
this is like pathetic
i kind of agree it's like thirsty it's
thirsty but like he is low-key thirsty
yeah what do you think about his
friendship with anyone like do i think
they're dating a lot of people do
i don't i don't um cause if they were
like they would yeah no exactly
but
if let's play the game like who if you
had to pair him up with somebody who
would you pair him up with probably me
okay
also did you see that jason momoa and
kate beckinsale left the oscars together
and were like getting handsy with each
other oh my god i'm gonna cry that's
like mama that's the best thing i've
ever heard i
literally would take a bullet for both
of them and honestly i think it's
age-appropriate and i hate when i say
the word age-appropriate cause i feel
like a mom with kohl's cash being like
shopping for a homecoming dress but it
is age-appropriate i agree and like
imagine that no that imagine that that's
how tired we are imagine how tired we
are of hearing it i think that that is
the best cup i think i never would have
paired them in my head no
i love that yeah and if i could name
one kate beckinsale movie i can't but i
can name what she wore in the paparazzi
photos with her and pete davidson at the
hockey game with anthony i couldn't
agree more like to everything you just
said except i do believe she was in
pearl harbor which is like a big movie
oh it's great yeah is she in it
yes she's the nurse so is jamie king
who's like taylor swift's best friend
who's also very underrated and do you
know her backstory i actually don't know
anything about her so she was a
supermodel and she was part of the
heroin chic era where like models were
extremely extremely skinny and she got
into drugs and she had this like 14 year
old boyfriend as well who was really
young but he was like the biggest
photographer how old was she at the time
she was 14. like she was like oh my god
okay
no she was running around new york they
were like these kids and like he was her
muse very like heroin chic model she got
into the dark scene it's kind of like in
one tree hill when brook like goes to
like the modeling convention i can't
talk about one time i know i was like
yeah i know please um and
then she like got clean and like turned
into an actress and then she's like
lemon on heart of dixie and in pearl
harbor if you go from pro horrible pearl
harbor heart of dixie i'm picking heart
a dixie obviously but uh yeah she has
like a really cool background i think
she should write a celebrity book i
think she should do i was going to ask
how you knew that did she write a book
no no i'm just like sick yeah oh another
pr question i had for you what do you
think is going to be the medium in which
brittany finally shares her truth
because i believe it should be a book um
i think it's going to be an oprah
interview
yeah because diane sawyer obviously is
so talkative we all know how that went i
i drink pepsi you know what i mean yeah
um i think i would love to see an oprah
interview with her just because i love
oprah i feel like if it's a book it
might not be as authentic because like
there's going to be other people writing
right with her i would love to see like
a re a genuine reaction where she like
doesn't have time to like think about
whatever their people want her to say to
actually just like speak her truth yeah
i don't know how she would translate on
camera imagine if she went on red table
talk dead there have been some iconic
moments on red table talk i'm not like
olivia jane
everything everything i literally sat in
the studio and watched it the moment it
came out yeah and i was like downloading
the facebook watch app yeah
literally
um and then there was like that other
table red table talk like with uh gloria
estefan yeah i also really liked the one
with the girl from grey's anatomy what's
her name the main character ellen pompeo
yeah she has a really good one as well i
like i like red tablets i've heard that
ellen popper is like not a nice woman
i've seen like multiple videos of her on
tik tok
of her like constantly saying no to
taking pictures with fans and i do
believe like as a celebrity it is
annoying and like you do have every
right to say no especially if you're
like with your family you're eating a
meal but like for every time your answer
to be no like that's [ __ ] rude can i
tell you the one person who's ever said
no to me who um i was in l.a i thought
you were going to say me i'm like [ __ ]
no i did not we took a picture we took a
picture i went to claudia's meet and
greet what show do we go to boston
wilbur
um
vince vaughn
no yes oh my god i love him yes i was at
a sushi restaurant and i was out in la
for the summer while i was in college
like interning and this is when i would
still like go up like you're gonna get a
picture with you of course um and he was
like no
i didn't give a reason it was just no
period no period there's no dot dot
there's like a california roll on the
table and i'm like i can't oh my god
that's horrifying i'm trying to think i
don't think i've ever been told no and i
think if i did like i would probably die
it's so embarrassing yeah and i
definitely i don't get like recognized
like a lot but i feel like in new york
and la i'll get recognized here and
there and i was sobbing in the airport
on the way home from the super bowl
because um my dog was sick and somebody
came up to me and was like oh my god i'm
sobbing not the time they were like oh
my god are you girl last night i was
like
yeah
not the time not the time but at the
time i was like yeah i mean i'll take
any type of recognition yeah of course
girl me too somebody opens the door for
me i'm like they know who i am i'm like
oh my god did you call me an instrument
yeah um well i love you i'm this was so
fun you have to come back you're an
amazing co-host thank you so much for
just like caring about all of this like
just as much maybe more than i care
about it thank you and i love that for
you i'm so happy for all of your success
everyone follow gbt on tick tock and on
instagram at girl boss town oh wait what
the [ __ ] is girl boss town so as a
marketing and branding queen myself
my name is the one thing that nobody
picks up on because it's like girl
boston because i'm from boston and live
in boston so it's like girl boss town
and
um yeah it's not a good look for my like
marketing and branding while it makes no
sense it's so unique and there's just so
much you can do with it like gbt so i
think it's actually good cool but now
knowing that it's a boston reference
that does change things but there's
meant to be pronounced girl boss town
yeah of course and there's a new abc
show called single
like sober female or whatever and it's a
girl who works at like an influencer
company in boston it's called girl boss
town
so i was like excuse me excuse me do you
trademarked um
in the process good good yes um well i
love you thank you also everyone follow
gbt her real name is robin but like
that's irrelevant because you were
always going to be gbt to me thank you i
love you guys thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so it's spotify
itunes central public radio i heard
accounts box all the places so wherever
you listen to podcast finance morning
show sleep five star view about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are hope
you guys have an amazing day and we'll
see you tomorrow for hump day our final
show of the week jackie will be joining
us remotely um and then i'm headed to
texas four shows i'm in austin thursday
dallas friday and then houston saturday
and sunday the shows are sold out except
for the final show in houston tickets
available at girl no job.com have an
amazing day we'll see you tomorrow bye
you